moi c'est que sont devenus ces petits
choux et d'un convoi y en a qu'on boit
moins on va commencer par benoît haut et
stork redonne un petit peu c'était un
combat d benoit c'était en 2010 ça fait
12 ans voilà et en disant chance coup
certains deviennent très beau d'autres
aussi le temps à aider souvenez vous de
son portrait la chirurgie et benoît
je m'appelle benoît j'ai 21 ans j'habite
à villeneuve sur yonne et je suis
coiffeuse
[Musique]
c'est une petite baisse jules morveuse
ma stratégie dans le jeu ça sera le
mensonge la manipulation qui fait savoir
me faire aimer obtenu tout ce que je
fais
et alors avant qu'on revienne sur ce qui
se fait aujourd'hui évidemment très
célèbre c'était plus est des cyclades
story voici pour son duo oui avec thomas
et une émission dans une émission les
gayssip boys on en a fait une pièce de
théâtre ça s'appelait les mauvaises les
mauvaises et c'était des brigitte et
josiane brigitte et josiane oui j'étais
brigitte seth est joseba c'était ça
bâtiment gascon dire qu'on fait ça on
s'en fout
richard t
hier la ville et sa combinaison hal a
dormi avec
tout fait dans la vie sociale et se met
à poil muni d'un petit torchon blanc
autour de la tan midi pour une fois
j'étais à avoir le bon jour d'une
testicules et aubrac marquis qui moulait
sont encore burma pas trop lointain oui
je peux vous dire que dans le slip à
bastia bout c
est là qu est ce qui devient devient ce
tomate est encore en contact bien sûr
alors il a habité pendant cinq ans à
londres il était dans l'équipe de
maquillage de chez dior et il vient de
revenir en france parce que ça lui
manquait et j'aimerais bien vous formez
un duo avec tout ça c'est un scoop maso
deux fois je les batteries mauvaises
comme horaire un goût un peu d'écho du
théâtre du alors sauté à trous soit une
petite phase i à l'antenne commenté la
presse people pourquoi pas ici
d'ailleurs la briseuse une fois leur
retour dans tpm pépites sur ces 8 à bail
et les producteurs lionel stand h2o
régime un monde dont la rillette quoi il
s'est évanoui sa main
ah on me thomas il a envie et là on vit
ouais non je dois dire que ça fait dix
ans qu'on n'a pas travaillé en
musique avant après mais c'est où nous
avons
alors là c'est vraiment parce que
maintenant c'est devenu un performeur et
rivera qui est sa vie pour des
performances
n'ont pas vraiment drag queen veron
créateur d'accord mais je fais
simplement soirée mais signalé en garde
sont toute la semaine alors est ce que
c'est vrai que quand tu as fait secret
story c'était extrêmement populaire tu
le sais pas tu es dorothée dans l'est
était dans l' aventure il ya un an et
envie de partir et grosso modo la prod
fait comprendre que ça serait bien que
tu restes ouais j'ai tout de suite
compris que j'étais favoriser de toute
façon par rapport aux autres là oui on
pouvait plus dans ma saison le matin
calme en attaque où brut a gagné
bas au bout du quatrième ou cinquième
prime à chaque fois qu'on était en
connexion avec la maison avec benjamin
c'était que derrière benoît benoît
c'était même très gênant par ailleurs
aux autres et du coup j'ai été nominée
tous les vendredis pour sortir parce
qu'il voulait absolument m'éliminer mais
se sont dit si on se retrouve en finale
face à benoît s'est perdu donc tout le
monde écoute le monde c'est de me faire
douter montauban et tu m'as dit quand
j'ai su que le jour de la finale il
paraît donc vous êtes 4 km chacun un peu
sur vallet ce première télé et nous met
il ya pour le show donc de l'antenne ou
n'a jamais fait de télé l'envoie à meeke
arrivait avec un casque dit toi tu vas
te mettre la toiture admettre la vous
tenez la main il y aura des shows
pyrotechnie machin et tout mais en
pression totale quoi et là on a compris
que effectivement ils étaient tous sur
moi quoi voir benoît c'est celui ci
écoute bien alors je sais pas si les
écoute bien benoît parce qu'ils ont vu
qu'il avait des lacunes
mais en tout cas j'ai bien compris que
tout le monde était sur moi c'est
incroyable comme et l'ado tueur retourne
en bourgogne oui en star une semaine
dans son village à mon dieu reçus par le
maire exactement je suis reçue par le
maire alors j'arrive dans le village
avec une énorme poche il n'avait jamais
vu ça dans le village non c'est bien par
claire moubarak
non mais avec le move et s'il s'avère
agents de sécurité sans ré 2
le petit pavillon de ma mère dans une
rue tranquille avec des paparazzis
devant chez ma mère une porsche à 300000
euros et touzet mais c'est qui qui
débarrassent que tu as amusant c'est que
en vrai et je te connais très bien les
gens le savent après table je fais des
docks surtout à tout ça après t'as pas
si bien vécu tout ça parce que tout
s'enchaîne on ne propose du théâtre avec
gérard louvin composent plein de choses
tu remets a pris au large et music
awards eux deux et là tu deviens un peu
dans un dock tu dis mais je suis devenu
spectateur de ma vie j'ai un peu pété un
plomb c'est quoi j'ai pas vraiment pété
un plomb mais ça c'est arrivé vraiment
comme une vague soudaine j'étais pas du
tout prévu à la célébrité moi je le
faisais pour l'argent je m'attendais pas
une suite comme ça tout de suite gérard
louvin a montré de la télé on m'apprend
que j'ai vu remettre un prix aux
énergies comme tu l'as dit et tout est
là tout va très très vite et je suis
spectateur c'est à dire que je deviens
transparent de moi même c'est à dire que
je suis un produit
marketing par les chaînes télé par tf1
par ça et du coup je deviens vraiment
une poupée qu'on met à droite à gauche
et je m'oublie totalement et je deviens
la caricature de moi même c'est à dire
j'étais quand même un personnage haut en
couleur mais là du coup ne sachant pas
vraiment comment exercer cette nouvelle
profession j'en rajoute je rajoute je
rajoute pour le protéger comme une
armure si tu veux et donc du coup ça a
marché finalement pas ce que je fais
huit ans sur nrj 12 au final ce n'était
pas le vrai moi c'est à dire que je me
suis fait passer pour quelqu'un d'autre
encore plus haut en couleurs que je
n'étais pour pouvoir exister me défendre
ce mais c'était pas dès le début parce
que là quand tu vois ta présentation par
exemple est-ce que avant de composants
et des droites en fait dès l'instant où
tu as commencé tu as finalement tiré le
trait de ce que tu étais illinois avant
ça tu l'aimés pas aussi excentrique
exact enfin si j'ai toujours était
excentré que la présentation là tu mets
les talons étoiles or il à la production
m'a demandé de mettre des talons de me
balader dans les champs à côté des
vaches avec des talons et ou bien sûr
j'avais des touches à moitié pour faire
le con le samedi soir avec mes amis
j'arrive à chercher le pantalon soit
c'était marrant c'est pas pratique si
bien que quand c'est fait le casting tf1
ne voulait pas de moi et endemol voulait
de moi parce que tf1 disait que c'était
trop la folle furieuse la tat du salon
coiffure et tout ce que j'étais ou entre
guillemets non mais du coup tu es fade
et nous on prend pas le dossier il est
trop lourd pour la ménagère de tf1 pour
secret story et endemol a dit il nous
faut absolument gamin qu'il nous faut il
nous faut et du coup ils n'ont pas pris
de risque qui m'ont mis sur internet
quelques jours avant cycle à cet horizon
et ci doit rentrer c'est le public qui
choisira le blâme entrée du coup
personne s'est mouillé et après je suis
sorti en dix ans j'ai adoré ma vie mais
c'est moi qui t'ai trouvé ses marques
est
ce que ça te vexe aujourd'hui quand tu
vois les audiences que ça fait sur tf1
pendant plusieurs semaines et la
canadienne non est ce que ça te vexer de
la question arrive après
lyon ça va c'est l'oeil team
rll souffrance est benoit dubois travail
tranquille est ce que ça te vexe voilà
le fait que tu vois les audiences que tu
as fait sur tf1 en prime et en
quotidienne pendant des semaines et
qu'au final quand tu demandes à faire
danse avec les stars on te disent ben
non tu es un peu trop caricatural pour
la chaîne on veut pas de toi alors c'est
pas ça on m'a pas pris pour ça dans
danse avec les stars c'est à dire qu'ils
ont su en effet paris oui mon pas pris
mais c'est à dire que le refus était
qu'il ya eu déjà une première candidate
de télé-réalité qui a participé qui est
et caroline receveur donc ils ont fait
un essai avec une candidate de télé
réalité parce qu avant qu'elle devienne
ce qui a été commencé un peu et vont
elles dans le dos ils ont pris car un
nouveau sauveur et à ce qui paraît il
était tellement chiant horizon dit plus
jamais on veut un candidat dans les
réalisera pas d'accord non mais souvent
les cognacs et l'arrêté sont plus tard
que les stars étaient au final on est
juste des people ou créent pas grand
chose mais on peut être loupé notre cul
et là si tu veux et baala griller tout
le monde et moi je dire qu'alors
aujourd'hui c'est les mystères de
l'amour oui où tu lui n'autorisant sur
le t3 et moyens truc que je ne l'étais
je te vois quand je te vois dans la rue
c'est qu'à chaque fois et je voyais
quand tu faisais le mag tu étais
paniquée par les gens et dès que tu
sortais quelque part c'est le capuche
jogging et tu marchais très très vite et
tout arrêter jamais besoin de cette
panique les gens c'est quoi ça me
panique pas c'est à dire que moi je suis
quelqu'un de profondément gentil et
j'aime pas refuser mais c'est à dire que
dans la vie si je me mets à faire défaut
à faire des photos ou à parler à tout le
monde ne serait ce que 5 minutes c'est à
dire que je mets une heure et demie pour
aller chercher un paquet de doliprane
puisqu un arbre mais c'est très très dur
c'est à dire de plutôt que de refuser
une photo ou de parler pour passer pour
un méchant devrait faire me cacher pour
éviter le refus d'accord il sera bientôt
une question que j'ai assumé résorbe pas
toujours perturbé le concernant
concernant benoît c'est que tu as fait
des retouches physiques dont tu parle
assez volontiers alors qu'ils avaient
absolument pas besoin pas sûr il ya des
noirs de france et du coup elle ça va
pas avec l'image de je me cache je veux
pas qu'on me regarde et moi je vais me
sentir beau moi je me fais pas bon pour
les autres avant tout donc c'est à dire
si je me cache mais que moi je me sens
dos à une affaire personnelle entre moi
et moi c'est à dire je met pas autant
d'artifices pour essayer de plaire à
quelqu'un d'autre mais autant
d'artifices pour essayer de me faire à
moi donc que je sois caché sais pas plus
que vous mr intelligente aujourd'hui
j'ai perdu voies côté mer davie en 5
secondes quand on était à nrj 12 la
nouvelle patronne nrj12 l'époque trouver
benoît un petit peu vulgaire et benoît
avait déclaré dans un journal je me suis
fait augmenter le sexe et je suis
convoqué dans le bureau génie mais le
mammouth et elle me dit enfin c'est
incroyable c'est vulgaire pour la chaîne
je veux parler à ce gamin je passe bien
je descends jeudi à guillaume je te
préviens la nouvelle patronne compagnie
veux te parler j'allais pas les lycées
et les dons à l'iran nos bureaux et la
nouvelle patronne comment elle
s'appelait la patronne prend le magazine
ou via une marque et je me suis fait
grossir le sexe et elle lui dit pourquoi
ça pourquoi et benoît répond ben j'ai
envoyé une plus grosse c'est parce que
je vous demande
je vous demande pourquoi vous en parler
à part dont j'avais vendu dans l'essor
du bureau je sais bien passé ben moyens
alors que ça reste pas au bout d'un an
et demi tout pas beau aucune transition
jamais qu'on parle un peu de nadège
nadège et qu'on repasse des images de
nadège quand elle gagne regardez la
cohue la folie nadège lacroix souvenez
vous elle
appelle un chèque de 150 millions
c'est seule
médaille ces messieurs
c
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme acquise
nadège grande gagnante emblématique est
magnifique alors plus belle qu'avant
c'est vraiment ébahis voulait pas sortir
aux tirs en panique totale mais moi
j'étais super bien la maille et pas de
facturer à payer les frigos et est tout
le temps plein j'ai pris dix kilos et
super vite ennuyée pas fait en fait vous
avez vécu un confinement avant tout le
monde sait tout et puis après c'était
sympa parce qu'il y avait toujours des
activités y avait plein de choses on
venait dans vos finalement organiser des
fêtes étrangers surtout bébé on en parle
était amoureuse de
maintenance et une autre qui viennent
quatre mille balles par moi qui te l'a
piqué mais souvenez-vous était même ton
secret
mais qu'est ce tu utilises
c'est leur a heureusement sitôt votre ce
qu'a découvert vous avez pu enfin vivre
un véritable conte de fées
sur l'otan chez footon
ça passe mais je peux me reposer un
petit peu tu veux moi plan couple plan a
lancé je mène
un amour indestructible basé sur
l'échangé la communication
[Musique]
était vraiment alors le secret c'est
thomas et mon frère le secret alors on
sait que les autres on rappelle que le
secret ils sont trouvés dans mon cul non
pardon jamais vulgaire bon pas bon non
pourquoi j'y vais et tu tombes vraiment
amoureux de thomas mais oui mais en fait
on est pas du tout rire et soeurs
honnête oui ça a duré 30 secondes pour
se traiter très fort et je commence à
tomber amoureuse de lui sauf que le
secret est pas encore découvert par les
autres habitants de la maison donc on se
retrouve demain tout simplement à avoir
toute relation moi je suis amoureuse de
lui mais je ne peux le dire à personne
parce qu'on ne peut pas être amoureuse
de son frère non et du coup huit
semaines après le secret est découvert
et du coup je peux lui annoncer que chez
amoureuse de lui et je suis trop
contente et je veux prendre le vent de
l'année devant 5 millions de
téléspectateurs ap ce absolument pas ce
qui allait lui l'était pas déjà il est
très amoureux de lui depuis très
longtemps
jamais d'ailleurs se vend cesser si je
pense à ta aider aussi à gagner parce
que les gens se sont attachés à toi moi
j'ai regardé toute la saison et en fait
son s'est projeté on s'est dit la pauvre
s'attacher à toi grâce à ce vent donc
merci thomas thomas nourrit de capucine
and has to set et consanguins de quatre
piscines à naves et puis après 2 2 bat
de nabila plus tard oui parce que tu
regardes a fait ses classes mais jamais
c'était le bon west à peu depuis tout ce
qui a suivi après c'est moi bien non
c'est parce que c'est qu'en fait si tu
veux me suis parti très jeune du coup
j'ai pas tellement eu d'adolescence
parce que je travaillais à 16 ans et en
fait je suis parti faire cette émission
j'avais déjà 25 ans et du coup j'ai
gagné deux mondes taille n'osait y est
gérée l'adolescence c'était superbe on a
fait est mental d'oseille à moi j'ai
profité
non moi j'écoute au voyage mois de
voyage actes et des mois mais j'aimerais
le après parce que l'après en vol c'est
peut être un peu compliqué benoît il a
une image tout le monde le connaît mais
il a une image forte donc aujourd'hui
fait les mystères de l'amour mais on
sait que si tu veux engager bonne
aujourd'hui c'est une étiquette que tu
engages toi ta came l'étiquette site
story dont on sort tout de suite est ce
que la presse que c'est pas pour la
presse regrette un petit peu et c'est là
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on a gagné
secret story ça un peu ma question après
dans mon cas moi je suis quelqu'un de
très simple ce n'est pas du tout
quelqu'un qui qui est fait pour la
célébrité on va dire ça quand même
derrière tu as été animatrice a été tapé
ma classe et moi j'adore ça mais jobs et
tous les challenges on m'a proposé après
j'étais super g fait sous le soleil
s'est toujours voulu être actrice et
donc du coup magique grâce à ces grades
story fait ça donc après on peut pas
cracher dans la soupe 6g et toutes ces
belles opportunités professionnelles
c'était grâce à ses petites amies oui
mais tu te pardon tu dis je suis pas
dieu comme quelqu'un qui aime la lumière
tes influences aujourd'hui bon je sais
que tu prends l'oseille en plein match
une fois qu'on t'a donné opportunité
pour exister sur les écrans et tu vois
que ça rapporte quand même très bien et
que c'est un métier confortable faut pas
être non plus idiot et puis à deux types
de candidats ya ceux qui participent
pour participer en one shot et il ya
ceux qui espèrent avoir quelque chose et
souvent ce sont des candidats mais c'est
parce qu'à regarder derrière une
bannière de télé réalité qui du coup est
la presse souvent deviennent des gros
influenceurs vous suis pas votre époque
que vous êtes sorti voilà les réseaux
sociaux est ce que vous n'avez pas le
côté un petit peu amer de vous dire là
aujourd'hui les nouvelles générations y
en a plein qui ont des millions de
couleurs qui gagnent beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent j'ai regardé les jeux regarder
vos contrats vous avez défouloir et tout
mais c'est une autre époque suis pas
dans les
championnats d après je suis apte au vu
de ce que je sais c'est girl power stone
facteur a pris la parole on est mort
juste avant moi sauf que c'est très bien
parce que comme on le dit souvent avant
c'était vraiment les productions qui se
servaient de nous et derrière on n'avait
rien et on passe à d'une notoriété de
dengue art devoir reprendre une vie
normale sans avoir besoin de façon à
voir ces fowler ça est-ce que ça a fait
l'erreur de placement de produits secs
en fait plus on a de notoriété plus on a
deux souhaits en fait plus la notoriété
elle baisse est plus salaires baissent
et puis on peut reprendre une vie
normale aussi donc je pense que c'est
ultra simple aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
t'es bavard tout à prix coûtant à la
dérive 4 apprenant mauvais du tout
aujourd'hui tu étais amoureuse oui j'ai
vu ça tu es heureuse oui j'habite paris
non non je danse je suis je ne sais quel
théâtre six comédiens exactement cet
éloge de l'avenir lutte et comédienne tu
joues est là on va faire avignon ça fait
dans nataf avionnais dernière s'est
plaint de deux salles différentes et ont
fait une tournée qui est super et mes
collègues sophie marion il avait perdu
son adorable et en formant un trio super
drôle donc et si vous êtes vers avignon
venez-vous a l'air très heureuse et très
épanouie et j'espère d'autant plus que
j'ai vu ça dans un documentaire il y
avait un moment de ta vie très
compliquée pendant deux trois ans tu as
été très malheureuse était sous
l'emprise d'un 6 ans pardon vous dis
dans le raid était sous l'emprise d'un
même d'un homme qui t'a fait beaucoup de
mal tout à fait j'ai grandi très vite on
va dire et c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui
enfin pour moi c'est cathy story c'est
vraiment avoir un conte de fées que j'ai
vécue parce que j'étais pas du tout
destiné à tout ça et je suis très
reconnaissante voilà bah t'es là très
épanouie ça fait très très plaisir bravo
heureux vacante et minéraux 3 et là on
va sur dur attention à cindy lopes oui
c'était quelle saison cindy six saisons
3 way est ce que toi tu es heureuse a en
fait cette émission moi j'ai tout à fait
heureuse après un moment donné bien sûr
comme beaucoup je pense que la notoriété
comme ça qui vient de nulle part ouais
ça pèse un peu sur les épaules quoi
d'accord n'a pas créé de vaccins on va
dire donc voila moi j'ai fait tout mais
les petits djaballah qui était rigolo
des petites créations après c'est sûr
qu'à un moment donné tu vois j'ai un peu
j'étais un peu usée par satya poésie
c'était comme un temps 3 6 4 un master
en 2009 2009 aujourd'hui j'ai fait un
one woman comme on est d'accord mais
est-ce que tu as pensons que donc 2009
oui des dix ans après c'est quoi c'est
un peu galère landes c'est un peu
compliqué c'est un peu fallait que je
prenne du recul pour faire un one tu
voir et discuter un peu de qui j'étais
vraiment et de comment j'avais vécu un
peu toutes ces histoires tout ce que
j'avais montré à la télé comme un enfin
je décortique un peu dans mon one woman
show
ma douche à poil long girl power mon
lait d'ânesse oui voilà longtemps été
réputée alors on va voir notamment
quelques coups de gueule il y avait ce
petit coup de gueule souvenez-vous le
les goûts tu as pété un plomb parce
qu'on avait piqué une crème et oui il y
avait du fonds la fermeté de la nes et
quand cindy s'énerve soirée baboule
bouger du chemin
ce jour je te jure je retrouve ma crème
cherchons non mais attends elle était là
dedans mais c'est marrant
à tort je rêve c'est qui qu'a pris
maquerelle qui est maintenant à moitié
vide je suis je vénère je n'ai pas eu la
même idée comme ça
c'est quelqu'un fiddle and the juice et
capri macramé démarre
incroyable cette crème
oui un peu névrosé on a tous des
névrosés serré dans une télé réalité sa
voix s'est un peu exacerbé et voilà jeté
un peu colérique parfois et aux non
appel alors tu as eu une image un petit
peu désiré pas vulgaire je n'aime pas le
mot mais tu as eu l'image un peu
sulfureuse on va dire et moi je pensais
même qu'après du coup tu allais avoir un
rôle un peu peut-être pas dans la
société mais comme tu disais girl power
tout le temps venu coutelle a affirmé un
peu les femmes à la balle affirmait la
position de la femme puis à une
mouvement mis tous derrière on n'a pas
trop vu ben écoute moi j'ai affirmé la
femme à ma façon après c'est sûr que
quand j'ai été approché par des
associations qui prenait toujours un peu
le néo féminisme et d'une certaine façon
des nanas qui défilait en jogging dans
la rue pour dire ni [ __ ] et voilà mais
tu vois ça me ressemblait pas je me
reconnaissais pas dans ce féminisme là
moi mon féministe c'était d'être qui je
suis comme j'ai envie de l'être et si
j'avais envie de porter un décolleté en
fait pour moi c'était pas de se
travestir en homme que d'être féministe
elle tr/min c'était ma façon à moi
d'être femme d'accord aujourd'hui que tu
es célibataire c'est moi je suis
maintenant j'ai des relations mais j'ai
deux enfants tu vois les noms oui
j'adore ce que tu vois chaque fois
non je sais pas tu as deux enfants ses
deux enfants et leur gentilles et sont
là
non grata devant moi mais là quatre ans
et demi raphaël 3 ans et est ce que je
me sens mal à se faire des choses et
c'était comme si tu sais mais alors pour
diminuer ah bon tu vas l'intérieur va
mais rattache les gants alors ton papa
ne faut pas que ça se perde tout ce que
tu enlèves qu'il utilisa ça va en face
ne sert à rien
bonjour mais un peu dans les fesses
aussi
j'avais du jus du kardashian je veux
dire c'est du bio au lait d'ânesse ma
chérie 1 quand même et là c'est vrai
qu'on parle que de choses qui sont très
jolie et très belle et tout ça il ya
aussi des moments très difficiles dans
ces quatre story tout le monde ne
supporte pas la célébrité et ta saison
c'était avec fx françois xavier était
très aimée avec lui mais on sait que
françois xavier s'est suicidé s'est jeté
sous une voiture on passe pas d'image
tout ça on n'a pas envie mais qu'est-ce
que ça ça t'a inspiré après ce que tu
t'es dit justement que vous n'étiez pas
assez préparée est ce que tu t'es taton
a voulu à quelqu'un à la prod est ce que
tu as qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça
dit de cette génération bas fx était
quelqu'un qui déjà avait une faiblesse
avant de rentrer dans le jeu c'est à
dire qu'il était déjà très jeune déjà
voilà il avait des problèmes de drogue
avant de rentrer dans l'émission voilà
il était issu d'une famille quand même
très aisés qui donc a fait ce qu'il
pouvait mais voilà dans un milieu où il
avait accès plus facilement à des gens
de déviance et je pense que la notoriété
l'a pas aidé peut-être avoir une
reconnaissance dans sa famille voilà
c'était une reconnaissance qu'il avait
besoin fx enfin voila il manque beaucoup
et c'est vrai que quand il ya eu la peau
quand la lumière s'est arrêtée parce
qu'a eu cette émission ensuite qui est
parti qui a pas marché du tout pardon
qui arrivent chaque année quand la
lumière s'est un peu arrêté sur lui l'a
très mal vécu c'est dans ces moments
qu'on se dit est-ce que c'est pas dans
ces moments où l'appareil pour loana ou
cocktail lumière s'arrête c'est là où il
faudrait peut-être soutenir ceux qui
sont les plus faibles la lumière
s'arrête où forcément au bout d'un
moment c'est pour ça qu'on court vite à
faire plein de projets on sort d'une
émission comme ça c'est ce que j'ai fais
d'ailleurs après quand on est trop jeune
et quand on fait ce genre d'émission
c'est sûr que c'est difficile après de
se relever et de se dire que non mais
c'est pas la vraie vie qu'on nadège
avait 25 ans 26 ans quand la feci crête
vont elles étaient déjà plus mature moi
j'avais 26 ans quand je suis rentré dans
le sucre est on sait que la vraie vie
c'est pas la célébrité on sait que moi à
chaque fois que je faisais mais tout ce
que j'ai fait après secrète pour moi
c'était du jeu j'ai jamais rien pris au
sérieux et encore aujourd'hui mais la
célébrité c'est pour de faux pour moi en
fait et lui il a vraiment cru que les
gens qu'il aimait les musulmans et les
gens qui ne le regardait plus n'est laid
mais plus tu vois donc c'était un peu
l'enfant maudit qu'on peut essayer de
faire voilà de se faire remarquer pour
qu'on l'ait qu'avant qu'on assuré bozizé
ans qu'est la très sage et tout ça et
c'est sûr on va on va aller à quelques
questions pour l'épauler petit shopping
et des baux est ce que vous et ses
proches de la famille daffix ou pas du
tout j'ai eu un petit bain si je devais
reprocher quelque chose à quelqu'un
c'est que quand fx tu vas nous a quittés
déjà moi j'avais du mal à balle assimilé
parce que ma quand tu quelqu'un de ton
entourage proche parent en fait c'est
important d'aller sur un an à
l'enterrement et voilà le le voir quoi
enfin voilà et en fait ils ont refusé
que l'on soit là nous ses amis proches
donc moi ça ça m'a été enfin je les
malpris moi je voulais après le décès d
fixe j'ai voulu bas répondre à es6 de ce
qu'il aurait voulu et il voulait qu'on
parle de lui partout donc j'ai accepté
absolument toutes les interviews de tous
les magazines parce que pour moi je
c'était pour lui que je faisais il n'a
révélé aucun suivi psychologiquement
avait ainsi baissé que légèrement la
plume de temps j'aimerais qu'on parle
moi je crois qu'après vont partir du
futur du vivions un pré accord
écologique après voilà il ya des gens
qui nous appellent qui prennent de
nouvelles preuves à l'appui on dit ce
qu' il n'y a pas de sup sicot losique et
les gens ils peuvent pas dire avec nous
enfin le dire à un moment donné on prend
note et c'est pas très lucide
on fait notre vie mais il ya de la
musique en oui alors pas de toi y'a un
jeune garçon que je vois je vois une
psychologue de la route
quant à l'or lui je sais pas c'est autre
chose aussi lui il est tombé amoureux de
sa maman ce
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qu'on vit à dunkerque dans l'eure en ce
moment alors pop idol nathalie vivian
même s'il vient plutôt mieux évolué que
sa maman on en parlera tout à l'heure
souvenez-vous de cette compil regarder
salue la voix moins saignant j'ai à
peine vingt deux ans et j'habite aussi
encore est-ce que vous dire qu'on passe
vraiment de bons temps j'ai rencontré
vivian il ya un an ça a été un véritable
coup de foudre la première fois que j'ai
vu je les trouvais magnifique mais
j'aurais jamais cru un jour être qu'une
femme déjà de son âge et puis surtout
d'une telle beauté au début on n'était
pas vraiment ensemble c'était juste on
se voyait de temps en temps comme ça
quand on avait envie quand j'avais envie
et un jour je lui ai dit je veux plus
partagé je te ferai pour moi c'est vrai
et j'ai accepté
c'était si critique t du malade tu mets
un peu cette histoire d'amour quand même
non non non c'était si gratuite et
d'heures mathieu avant tout ça j'ai une
surprise pour toi comme tu es mon client
numéro 1 sur mym j'ai un petit cadeau
pour toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
d'accord
c'est toi que tu vas la planche du fakir
tu dois savoir où l'on va arriver sur
les abdos un
[Applaudissements]
chronomètre est magnifique quand elle
vient aux gens parce que tout le monde
connait pas pardon c'est quoi mims
c'est un site de sexuel
donc tu t'es sorti
pour prendre ou va si du côté sur mym
pardon tu étais tu n'as qu'à ça non mais
quel corps c'est un petit club et pour
beaucoup même l'école si quelqu'un un
clin d'oeil à faire elle n'hésitait pas
à la pente au micro en main parce que du
coup
pardon j'ai glissé à la la c'est pas
possible elle est maladroite s'apprend
sable puissance mais voilà alors à
l'époque y avait cette histoire avec
nathalie tu étais vraiment amoureux mois
s'il faut savoir c'est que j'étais
vraiment gros nathalie secretstory ils
nous ont demandé des preuves comme quoi
un thème ensemble ce qui est beaucoup
truc fait qu'à l'époque on avait deux
ans de photos et on a été pris donc du
coup voilà c'est un truc de fou et
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la réponse à la
question par des tubes du bras vont
directement oui ou non mais les ténors
maintenant c'est un couple fakes et
j'ai dit oui c'était la vérité oui
mais c'était vrai
aujourd'hui plein de trucs aulas est
maintenant
non un bricolage les rideaux de la
couture non moi je suis venu ici c'est
que pour des bras voilà j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] du reste
voilà en fait il faut que je te dise le
premier jour je t'ai vu à la télé j'ai
arrêté toutes les conneries tu vois tout
ce qui est voilà un porno claquettes
chaussettes et ou à la télé c'est fini
c'est pourquoi ça me gêne parce que j'ai
fait le sujet te prépares tu as fait ton
coming out ya quelques
mois j'avais pas fait un comédien non
c'est une blague à qu'on ait vu avec une
salle n'ont donc pas vraiment amoureux
des bornes non mais en fait dévorer
depuis que j'ai vu j'ai changé voilà
donc j'avais été invité à dunkerque chez
ma mère on s'est dit prêt à inventer des
deux d'ailleurs je t'ai fait une fiche
de moi si tu veux dire tu peux dire
qu'il va à nouveau surprise générale
euros mathieu sortir mon colis s'est
passé